I cannot notice this the other day women
don't want to be over drivers like women
are saying that you know that there's
this opportunity if you know
opportunities for dude [ __ ] I'd love
to have a lady pick me up
you know you think I wanna do but he's
not matter you think I want a young gay
man handing me a butterscotch every day
from the front seat that's a little bit
warm and keeping the windows down while
we ride what the [ __ ] is going on dude
I'm in the back of a hooking man's car
eating a butterscotch with the windows
down dude and not getting molested bro
yeah baffling I mean that is why it's a
backseat like yeah I've had a couple
guys like why don't you Java get behind
you and I don't know man one time an old
lady this Persian lady she was a worse
[ __ ] driver her husband must have
just cut her off financially yeah and
she was driving the airport I said man I
said I cannot it was unbelievable and
she let me drive and I [ __ ] drove us
to the airport and her uber no [ __ ]
work yeah pretty cool man and it was a
Ford Taurus that she had somebody pain
into them cells with like a like kind of
a rose gold collar and like it was a
piece of [ __ ] you ever have a coked-up
uber driver yeah it's great they go
through red lights and I go oh [ __ ]
and then back up if you like you already
through it man calm down like where
you're gonna put an engine head where
are you going I'm putting it in just
wait a second just keep going you're
fine through another Fred light it's
crazy yeah like I do my repla my C both
are like why why you put it on the click
of it makes it like keep quiet down back
there
five stars right show me show me
I was in uh Illinois like rural Illinois
yeah and we eat we'd eaten some acid
right we got four these cops into the
convertible okay dude who is wintertime
right and so they're like all right put
the cup put the car put the top up get
home you know they let us off didn't
realize we're on LSD right so we go
drive and offer on these back roads
[ __ ] living it up and dude the Sun is
coming up and we found ourselves on the
exact same Road headed right back where
the [ __ ] cops are and they're still
sitting there it's like two hours later
and we're like
no [ __ ] way the only place we could
not go is right here and we can't
[ __ ] turn around the house with you
so here's you can see a competent stop
we're going after that yeah dude I
remember we put the top back downs and
we thought there would be less car for
the cops - see you soon - bye
so maybe they wouldn't see us as slow as
possible thinking maybe we were making
too much noise because this everything
makes so much noise on acid and we were
just quiet and they're just like oh all
went straight to jail direct I got all
three got taken into the county
courthouse really oh yeah
directly but broke the [ __ ] moment
were passing behind his hope and they
wouldn't [ __ ] hear us probably doing
four miles an hour with the top down on
the [ __ ] frigid morning in rural
rural Illinois that was the last thing I
heard somebody say before the lights
went up you know it's crazy as my sister
can't even read but what does it have to
do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options
watch one this one